[Musique]
chaque jour un million de personnes
s'achemine vers le centre de la région
parisienne ou regagnent leur domicile
par y en at il un gramme par ses
habitants d'abord et bon nombre de
résidents de banlieue de lyon leur
emploi un million de personnes
franchissent journellement l'époque de
pain 800000 viennent de l'extérieur
travailler à paris 200 milles son
inverse c'est-à-dire va pas rayer à
l'extérieur un sur cinq utilise autobus
un sur dix utilisent des voitures
particulières 14300 taxi assure chaque
jour le transport de 450 mille personnes
par jour sur le trajet de la voie
express en compte et 7000 véhicules à
l'air soit 76 8 voitures par jour
circuit lent sur trois fils sans
itinéraire de dégagement ajoutons à cela
deux cent trente mille voitures en état
de stationnement parce que permanent
dans nos rues elle occupe à elle seule
25 % de la surface des chaussées en
période de pointe dans le centre de
paris
alors complètement congestionnées c'est
60% de la surface restante pour publie
véhicules automobiles choix 95 %
d'occupation des voies publiques
voilà en quelques chiffres l'état de la
circulation à paris
[Musique]
cette et hier matin 11 heures sous une
pluie fine mêlé de quelques flocons de
neige
la voie express qui permet depuis 7h de
traverser paris d'ouest en est était
inaugurée par monsieur georges pompidou
entouré de monsieur christian fouchet
ministre de l'intérieur roger frey
ministre d'état chargé des relations
avec le parlement andré bord secrétaire
d'état à l'intérieur maurice doublé
préfet de paris et michel caldaguès
président du conseil des pins dans la
déclaration que le premier ministre
devait faire après le voyage inaugural à
l'hôtel de ville de paris
monsieur georges pompidou déclaré on a
trouvé le moyen de faire traverser tout
paris par une voie moderne sans en
altérer le site
[Musique]
automobilistes depuis hier matin sur une
distance de près ce qu'il omet la voie
express rive droite vous permet de
traverser paris d'ouest en est sans
aucune signalisation entre le quai du
point du jour et la rue wilhem la voie
sur berge fut mise en service le 30
septembre 66 pour permettre de franchir
le pont de grenelle à niveaux séparés et
assurer la liaison des deux tronçons de
la voie sur berge en direction la maison
de la radio
une nouvelle voie provisoire à une seule
file fut ouverte le 15 juin 65 cependant
la construction du nouveau pont de
grenelle entraînant sa fermeture
comme vous pouvez le constater cette
voie est rétablie sur 2 de la rue
beethoven à la place de la concorde la
voix n'utilise pas les berges basse
occupé par la navigation et le salon
nautique nous voici donc au premier
souterrain vienna place de varsovie
mise en service en 1937 fut rénovée
dernièrement au point de vue éclairé
le deuxième est celui de l'alma mise en
service en 56 le premier de tous les
sous terrains comportant à peu près les
mêmes caractéristiques que le premier
le passage souterrain cours la reine qu
albert 1er mis en service le 1er juillet
66 permet d'éviter les carrefour du pont
des invalides et du pont alexandre iii
voici des images des travaux de ce
souterrain long de 300 19 mai à noter
que les plantations placé sur le
terre-plein exister cours albert 1er
pure sérieusement remanié et près de 600
arbres déplacer en ce qui concerne le
passage souterrain place de la concorde
mise en service long juillet 1967
les travaux ont été réalisés en totalité
à ciel ouvert mais il fallut pour
libérer le sous sol de tous les réseaux
de câbles et de canalisations vais
réaliser 385 m de nouvelles galeries
dans lesquels furent installés les
réseaux et les qualifications
cet ouvrage permet de rejoindre le quai
des tuileries
depuis le cours la reine est aussi
depuis les champs elysées à partir des
quais des tuileries et des quais du
louvre
il fallut souvenez vous réalisez un
viaduc plus connu sous le nom de
toboggans ainsi qu'une voie sur berge
provisoire ces deux ouvrages ayant été
inaugurés respectivement les 8 et 15
novembre pour la voie provisoire des
semelles en béton armé furent installés
sur des pieux de 0 mètre soixante de
diamètre qui descendait jusqu'au sol
calcaire qu'on a compté sur ce tronçon
1400 voiture 1
le viaduc lui était construit avec des
travées d'une portée de 15 mètres
chacune qui était constitué par deux
longerons enfer s'appuyant sur les
portes
il a coûté à la ville de paris 3
millions 500 mille francs soit environ
15% du coût complet de la construction
du souterrain du pied du doubs qui lui a
été mis en service hier sa longueur 860
mètres sa hauteur 3 mètre 92 il a été
réalisé en 13 mois
parmi ses caractéristiques croft non
cette usine de ventilation dont va nous
parler maintenant monsieur aux
ingénieurs des travaux publics
ces usines donc prennent d'affaires
prennent l'air sur la berge et là
souffle
ailleurs des tunnels par l'intermédiaire
d'une galerie qui se trouve sur le côté
droit de la chaussée et les revit sied
repris en trois points des jurés est
renvoyé également son labeur je vois
qu'il faut signaler cette fameuse porte
blindée à la sortie du tunnel louise les
terrains oui enfin blindé est un bien
grand mot disons que c'est une porte
étanche qui est roulante et qui est
destiné en cas de crue de la seine donc
de mettre le souterrain à l'abri des
eaux
mais pour réaliser ces travaux
gigantesques qui lui pour parler de tous
les ouvriers qui ont travaillé souvent
dans des conditions difficiles
convient-il fallu d'ouvriers sur ce
chantier monsieur chabert ingénieurs
conducteur de travaux lourds et peu
moins de même de nos avions 350 ouvriers
sur le chantier en majorité main
d'oeuvre étrangère
c'est une chose qui se
portugais et espagnols quelques italiens
et nord africains vous avez maintenant
après qu'un jour et nuit
nous avons travaillé à deux postes
surtout pour le souterrain un poste de
terrassement et ensuite un poste de
voyager mais tonnage pour le radier du
souterrain
est-ce que l'eau
au point bon nous avons dû faire des
rabattements de nappes pour travailler
nous étions sous l'eau 20 cm à peu près
de livres 280 mètres environ
différents abattements à votre manche
général de manor est ce que vos hommes
ont l'habitude de travailler sur ce
genre d'ouvragé je crois que
l'entreprise avait fêté chantier
à peu près analogue périphérie nous
aurons c'est le périphérique un pantin
la porte de la chapelle et la porte de
la chapelle
ensuite il ya une chantier de la
concorde et nous avons fait ce champ
qu'il ait chanté du dollar et du louvre
au pont de sully de kilomètres de voies
sur berges ont été construits exigeant à
certains endroits la construction d'un
mur chaise en béton armé ce tronçon est
venu rejoindre la voie sur berge sud lit
en service depuis le 24 juin 65
[Musique]
vient ensuite le passage souterrain
bercy qui est destinée à livrer le
passage à la circulation de la rive
droite qui est à double sens dans ce
secteur et enfin le passage souterrain
du pont de tolbiac construit en bordure
des anciennes caves d'entrepôts de vin
constitue les 13 km de voies sur berge
qui permettent maintenant d'éviter
depuis le boulevard murat 24 ponts du
fronton de paris où le souvenir du grand
pelotaris shikito de cambo rivaux
religieusement conserver aux guinguettes
de joinville le pont c'est la promenade
touristique à 60 km à l'est recul en
fera peut être à partir d'aujourd'hui
c'est entre les nouveaux pans du point
du jour est celui très récent du
garigliano que l'on emprunte la voie sur
berge en point d'orgue la tour eiffel
dominera longtemps le paysage parisien
tandis que les nouveaux buildings du
front de seine commencent à dresser leur
architecture puissant le pont mirabeau
construite en 1895 par genre et zale et
d'un remarquable spécimens architecture
métallique avec son arche unique à
grande portée
le souvenir de dire la pauline air
flotte sur les eaux qu'il domine voici
le nouveau pont venelles la statue de la
liberté réduction de la statue colossale
érigé à l'entrée du port de neuer par
bartholdi le précèdent en figure de
proue la maison de la radio 2000 arrive
de son immense bâtiment annulaire
dominée par une tour de 65
nous avons bordel ils dessinent ou
anatole france fit rêver
jérôme coignard voici le pont de bir
hakeim que le métro sûrement depuis 1906
les assises du pont d'iéna sont décorés
des aigles de l' empire il est entouré
du palais de chaillot y fait face à ces
vous équestre
tandis que la tour eiffel en cas vrai
peut-être renferme le magnifique façade
l'école militaire du hamas gabriel le
musée d'art moderne avec ses sculptures
d'aristide maillol l'ile-de-france et la
montagne
continuons notre chemin en sortie de la
place de l'alma le monument au poète
polonais mx fx héros de l'indépendance
par bourdais mais déjà survient le grand
panneau et sont à bruges modern style
jetant dans le ciel de paris ses sabots
couleurs des spirales la statue équestre
d'albert 1er roi des belges le roi
soldats bronze par armand martial datant
de 1938 avant de s'engouffrer dans le
souterrain de la concorde une vue de
l'ancien place louis 15 puis de la
révolution et de son obélisque femmes en
sort près du musée de l'orangerie et
déjà se dessine au loin la silhouette
harmonieuse du pavillon de flore dont la
façade domine le pont royal
un kilomètre des circulations
souterraine l'on découvre à hauteur de
l'hôtel de salle qui abrite la
chancellerie de la légion d'honneur la
garde horse et sa grande horloge
construite en 1898 sur les ruines du
palais dorcé incendiaires 1871 par la
commune ici la voix royale remonte
l'échelle du temps l'institut de france
et sa coupole fameuse le palais de
justice et sa façade sur la rue de
harlay évoqué par anatole france dans
les bureaux soif près de lui la
conciergerie ou habitèrent les empereurs
romains puis les premiers rois capétiens
bouleversé par les révolutions et les
architectes immeuble sinistré puissants
ou les girondins chantèrent et où
marie-antoinette espira au milieu des
ombres tourmente et chantée par enrichir
l'hôtel-dieu vaste hôpital reconstruit
en face de la fondation du moyen-âge une
prévision sur la flèche dans sainte
chapelle
le dom du panthéon
[Musique]
les tours de notre-dame et puis les
beaux hôtels de l'île saint louis où le
souvenir de baudelaire fréquentes
l'hôtel loser lille finit en douceur par
ce bel immeuble aux formes courbes
habiter en son étage par michèle morgan
la nouvelle faculté des sciences c'est
pas le long du quai saint bernard la
gare d'austerlitz annonce la sortie du
paris des arrêts de l'histoire pour
celui non moins pittoresque du labeur et
des vins des palais de paris aux maisons
de notre histoire des quais littéraire
au quai de bercy
la voie express nous amener dans ce
pittoresque charroi 10 ans leur nom de
la bourgogne ou de baudelaire bientôt
voici les chevaux du champ de courses de
linselles joinville-le-pont la marne et
ses gains
une rivière en bresse du petit vin blanc
des frites des cas boulot et des
champions
c'est la nouvelle traversée de bain
[Musique]